I don't review with my mind I get that
he reviews his mind and forgotten the
face of his father I review with my
heart they don't ever tell you what the
hell he means when he says that makes
you forget the face of your father or
something there appeared a lot and
walked out were like lapels that even
mean they repeat the gun slingers create
a bunch of times they bother to go like
both of our main characters have lost a
father and they they never really the
line doesn't match on it much yeah
you're starting to go wait a minute what
but you're killing all these people with
a gun anyway thank you like what if you
didn't have a gun would you be able to
still do something usually
what is happening reject nation it's
Greg Alva here and it's John over here
so we came back from watching the highly
recommended and highly rated the dark
Wow our oh don't start off your reviews
being sarcastic Greg lamb because this
movie sucks if you guys don't know the
dark towers about basically you know
there's a you there's this universe
there's the earth and in this centre of
like the worlds there's this dark tower
that helps keep out bad forces yeah they
represent everything by a ring and at
the center of the ring is the tower and
all the different realms and worlds and
universes and stories live within this
ring and there's some unknown evil
outside of it the door however protects
the ring from and someone wants to
destroy the tower in this story Matthew
McConaughey's character the man in black
otherwise known as Walter Odum he wants
to take down the dark tower because he's
life think of him like the devil that's
kind of what he is evil got evil guy one
mad dog who behaves like Matthew
McConaughey the gunslinger played by
Idris Elba roland deschain who is
someone who has this very specific beef
with the man in black and it's just his
job as a gunslinger to help protect the
Dark Tower that's just his main job in
life the calling of vocation and ancient
do Knight and that's all cool but this
doesn't really focus on that as the main
plot when this movie shuts up it's
really about this little white guy named
Jake chambers played by this actor named
Tom Taylor who's actually pretty damn
good in the film interest Elba he's
enjoyable Matthew McConaughey's
enjoyable probably because I already
like it Versova and I already like
Matthew McConaughey and I was excited to
them on-screen at the same time though
they are kind of just one no
performances I think both of them are
this movie doesn't do any of its cast
favors but there are certain
performances that are still pretty good
and Tom Taylor as Jake chambers he's the
only one who really has like emotional
depth which kind of gets canned here and
there no one in this movie is really
responding to the stakes at hand really
bothers me especially like is it the
gunslinger and the men in black they all
have
like calm cool approach to no matter how
dangerous or scary or whatever the
situation is they're just they're even
Jake chambers he's like the emotional
character in it the one who were you
know he's the one who were being
introduced into this world through but
even there's times where she's not his
characters not really being so my god
the world's about to end you know I
really no one's really responding to the
gravity of anything yeah when the movie
itself doesn't really do a good job
communicating the stakes or the
suspension or the danger really itself
either so just none of that hits kind of
ever the whole part of the movie all all
the moments and then big suspenseful
things they're all just kind of people
just telling you what's going on oh it's
this is like so exposition it really
feels like the four riders of this film
had a beat sheet and they all said to
themselves what information needs to be
said here who can say it alright good
let's just write that information down
there's nothing not a single moment in
this film that's just left to body
language like giving it away or letting
the audience for you everything heaven
be made laid out perfectly clear all the
time and there's not a lot of extra
dialogue for anything they don't want to
extra like Heather's mom men have even a
little thrown out things which is why
when they do show up once in a while you
notice them you're like oh yeah there's
two plot lines here the gunslinger he
has a dad his dad died was killed by the
man in black and all unit was Killian so
he has a very specific vendetta with the
man in black he just wants to kill
didn't care about protecting the dark
tower anymore and the main character
Jake chambers his dad died and the film
starts off with having like expositional
backstory on all that but if you picture
of me and dad I'm yeah back on the shelf
even the therapy scene II had disclosure
I've been in therapy for a few years
Jon's go sit there and we know plenty of
people who go to therapy and even the
therapy dialogue well even though it's
in therapy I'm like this even feels
expositions like you're trying to get
information yeah even in a geremy's
being I'm going judging it real hard
none of the conversation especially for
the first part of the movie like none of
the conversations feel
nan-oh at all and and there's not much
the actors can do to make them feel that
way and we oughta just be an
expositional it's just bad dialogue a
lot of it is really poor screenplay
writers from adapted from Stephen King
is great epic source material and I've
never I've inaudible are so conventional
I've never read The Dark Tower books I
know about Stephen King and I write ya
know like I can't imagine he's please
all with this because like there are
four writers on this script that are
credited and it doesn't sound like any
one of them did more than a first draft
nap on any of this dial my understanding
is the dark hour has a lot of
description in it and I feel like maybe
the writers just kept taking description
and just throwing that in a dialogue
instead of taking actual dialogue these
characters probably have with each other
from time to time supposedly there's a
TV series still in the works but watch
on this felt like I watched an entire
series condensed into an hour and a half
why is this only an hour and a half not
that I wanted to kick it any longer with
everyone to be two and a half hours but
you could have had time to flush things
out if you were under this like pressure
to make it a 90-minute film if it's
clear that your movie needs a name extra
key elements you know a short run time
you know expanding a little bit is is so
plot heavy information they kind of
treat a chancer opportunity to care
about anything I kind of feel like they
treat the audience like we should
already know a lot of this like we
should have written Arabic every moment
to remind you of everything that
happened and everything that I make and
blah blah blah and it's work is like if
you look around the rest of the movie it
seems like they forget a lot of the
other important details yeah
even physically even in some of the sets
and stuff the effects are surprisingly
good like the effects are all right she
is pretty good Gigi's pretty good
there's there's a very specific fight
that goes down between Idris Elba
Matthew McConaughey totally reminded me
of like a video game type of fight gun
slinger versus guy with like someone and
a telekinetic yeah exactly
I thought like the special effects
actually don't look too bad here and the
action scenes did result like he kicks
serious ass and the action scenes he's
cool you know there's there's one fight
where he's
actually like injured and trying to heal
and the way they shot that and whenever
he liked would just whip out a gun and
just casually shoot like a ninja like
character it was pretty sweet actually
and yeah the final fight was pretty
sweet I got heart ball one moment though
there's at that moment that they show in
all the trailers where he's giving this
the gunslinger speech you know I don't
even read my mind or yeah he forgets
about his father but this is once in one
moment of the show in the trailer he's
going all daredevil like and he closing
his eyes because he's trying to shoot
the guy who took the kid they show it
all on the trailer in the trailer that
seems pretty sweet it is and in the
movie and remember he is aimed that's
nice that was one of the few scenes
where we tapped into somebody what's
going on in the night of somebody in a
visual way and it got intriguing for a
minute well ruin that whole moment for
me was right after when the guy gets
shot they show that where the guy got
shot wasn't that far away from where the
gunslinger was what if the gunslinger
just ran a little bit more got into the
open field was this kid wasn't so you
could have had it just a clear shot
instead of spending like 45 seconds it's
all this breathing stuff I'm like well
appointed doing all that man's essence
like walk over a little bit find your
opening and shoot the guys yeah or what
it's really ruined by that moment is
really ruined by editing because it's
like he fires the shot you see the thing
and then immediately the kids there yeah
you should have at least given us a
little a couple extras to show that
distance happened because you know the
scene starts you're like oh he doesn't
know where he is he has to do this yeah
beam ends and the kid shows right up
here like I yeah yeah he's just over
there doing it was the point of all that
I think some of the action is cool I
think some of the visual elements they
bring in especially in that scene are
kind of cool but even the cinematography
in the editing of this movie aren't that
appealing or they work to me it's not
like the the angles are exquisite or
anything there are a lot of times where
they're just kind of serviceable at best
they had an element in it I had a couple
of scenes that actually worked they show
you in the trailer so I don't mind
giving it away were
the gunslinger has to come to our he
comes to New York City Jason Takes
Manhattan
yeah and when they play out that scene
he becomes like Wonder Woman you have to
use a fish out of water who doesn't
understand any of this stuff works and
there's a couple times where it's really
often just kind of weird and you could
really tell that the writers resistance
is appreciated water man there's a
couple of scenes there that are actually
really funny and how Idris Elba handles
it and say I thought that was fine but
this film is the definition of wasted
potential at every given moment you
could have just expanded this out you
why not go for a two hour runtime I
don't get why you
I feel like an extra half hour would
have done this movie a lot in order to
flush it out give us some character
seems writing was just really awful a
lot of opportunity for more personal
investment the stakes or not fell yet
the stakes are technically huge yet
there's nothing as fell I don't feel
anything when I watch this movie
well they don't show you more than they
tell you hardly ever and sometimes
they'll show you what they've already
told you twice and tell you extra yeah I
like Dedra Selva I like the Maine kid
and beyond that everything could have
been better you know ever and it just
depends on to what degree you know it
sort of fell like why novel yes so well
yeah and then I haven't read any of
these like he knows a why novel
adaptation is more I kept thinking of
like the host and in the beginning
because in the beginning when they're
setting all this of them liked actually
pretty cool
I wonder cool but then as it progresses
it plays out like a ye adaptation if
this was a why a book and we saw this
movie I'll just be like okay like it's
another one of those but it's lie also
is coming from Stephen King who I know
like yeah there are a lot of these books
it seems like a pretty thick mythology
and there are things in the movies that
aren't cool ideas you know that are
carried over and stuff yeah it comes off
more like that than a Stephen King Oh
totally oh I felt like this would have
been cool like YouTube movies instead if
you go shopping but yes some dudes made
and they put it up on YouTube and I feel
like we all would have been like that's
a pretty cool sweet adaptation these
guys made I'm a really low budget no man
they get some funny name we get into an
actual movie really questions - yeah
and they don't have to worry about it
being so economical yeah what I was
telling you for a couple weeks prior to
any reviews or anything coming out on
this film of why I thought it was going
to suck see I was unaware of all the
production problems of some hat I didn't
know about any of that what made me
think this movie is going to suck is the
trailer and not because the trailer
sucks it was because I saw that this is
based on a Stephen King novel and the
trailer is a bunch of really cool action
scenes yeah and it made me go the action
might be cool which it was here but I
don't think Stephen King just wrote
eight books worth of action to write
like a cool blockbuster with a sky
portal yeah like when I'm watching like
the crazy action scene at the end where
it Rahzel bows having this crazy shoot
I'm like I don't think Stephen King
wrote all that in the book describing
any of this going down I felt like the
studio probably did was they took this
world turn it into more of a cool action
movie instead of really understanding
what the source material is that's not
happy that's what I felt when I saw the
trailer just because yeah it's a cool
trailer actions cool but I feel like the
characters and the movies and suck and
Annette and McConaughey is going to be
rather like a OneNote villain and sure
enough exactly what the movie was yeah
and then it ends up feeling like that
sort of casting reel like oh these guys
are really hot right now every loves
them BJ I like to hear they're in the
Stephen King's England's bring em in and
like I like to yourself I even though he
didn't have tons to do and I actually
like Matthew McConaughey less it's like
I like him generally speaking but
especially as a main piece of this movie
you know he's kind of chewing up the
scenery and none of his dialogue seems
like you've gotten off set you know and
it looks weird he looks kind of weird
his hair keeps changing and it's just
like at a certain point yeah he just
kind of looked like he showed up to play
a villain guy and that's fine but again
it just takes away suspense and it takes
away you know things to get really
invested in it's not surprising and
seeing Matthew McConaughey you know
being this mysterious man in black like
you want some kind of really cool
character performance and there are hits
in the background some other scenes
worth like talking to orbs and doing
and those things are neat but we just
never get to know how you know beyond
that and so he's just kind of a villain
for the film that tries to build a
Stephen King universe what an insult I
feel like Stephen King oh you're 1408
references and your shining stuff and I
come on man like you oh it feels nothing
like Stephen King this feels like what
Universal did with the dark universe
yeah I feel like you owe it to really
any writer but especially writer as
prolific as Stephen King and if it's
seven Kings yeah especially right now or
Tolkien or whoever CS lute you should
you should make sure the writing of your
script are no priority did operating
system Todd I guess if I were to give it
a rating my rating would be since we
make these up every week wait for it to
come out on one of your internet
streaming devices where you're already
paying monthly for something where you
get access to a bunch of movies and then
they just add the dark cabrito but
that's when you should like this movie
I wouldn't say go ahead and rent it at a
red box I wouldn't say go watch it in
the theaters I was a one-hit way trailer
hitch shutter a movie for doesn't belong
on that trinket sir yeah it's really
horror I guess no in its Netflix or
Amazon video whatever then watch it I
give this movie a like revolver like a
six-shooter revolver but it only has two
bullet
well guys dude would you think of the
Dark Tower did you read the books and
loved it or did you not read the books
and loved it subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell -
on Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram go
check out our patreon